[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with the
daily mirrors associate editor kevin
mcguire and the columnist and
parliamentary sketch writer for the
telegraph madeleine grant they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight so let's see what's on some of
those front pages
the metro accuses the prime minister and
the foreign secretary of being asleep at
the wheel over the uk's role in the
changing situation in afghanistan
the guardian notes that 11 former
cabinet ministers were among those
expressing their anger at the prime
minister's handling of the situation
the telegraph reports that mps hold us
president joe biden in contempt over his
decision to withdraw american troops
despite the upheaval
and that's the same for the front of the
times
the express has a slightly different
take on the debate focusing instead on
the prime minister backing his approach
to the withdrawal
the mirror's verdict is simple johnson
humiliated
the star invites boris johnson to take a
long hard look at the face of the little
boy on their front page saying shame on
you
the mail turns its attention to foreign
secretary dominic raab who it says
failed to make a crucial call to his
afghan counterpart about the urgent
airlift of translators instead the call
was delegated to another foreign office
minister
and the financial times leads with a 16
billion takeover bid in the u.s
involving two of the world's biggest
futures trading companies
and we're joined tonight by kevin
mcguire and madeleine grant evening to
you both i mean the paper is pretty
unanimous
in their coverage of this story this
evening uh let's turn to the metro first
uh kevin and um
asleep at the wheel the headline they're
focusing
on
the
stark and scathing criticism of both
boris johnson and dominic raab today
no absolutely from the labour leader kia
starmer who will be delighted at that
headline and the matt rowe while in
downing street and the foreign office
they will be uh despair because he the
essential charge was uh the foreign
secretary and the prime minister let the
country in afghanistan down were on
holidays when kabul was was falling and
that that will strike home and
i went there the commons to watch it and
what was
what was very noticeable is few
conservatives attempted to defend the
prime minister who who waffled was a bit
lackluster knew he was in trouble likes
to bask as the new
winston churchill has more neville
chamberlain
over what's happened with with
afghanistan and the the media coverage
will be uh will be lacked up by labor
and it will have many concerns in in
despair because i think those
those allegations that uh they were
asleep up the wheel that the casualness
and incompetence of johnson on this
issue has resulted in
measures not being taken that should
have been
done better to get people out of
afghanistan earlier
you know it's it sticks because there is
a large element of truth in it
yeah madeleine uh the labour leaders are
kissed armor talking about a dereliction
of duty you cannot coordinate an
international response from the beach
yes it was a very good line and yes as
kevin says he'll be delighted that it's
on on the on the front page and i was
like i was i was just really struck by
the sheer level of fury amongst
backbenchers on all sides um and it
wasn't just at the government for
failing to prepare or foresee the chaos
although there was clearly a great deal
of anger on that front but there was
serious anger at the laid at the feet of
uh president biden in america at nato i
mean from all sides of the house rarely
do you see the chamber being so united
on anything and in all of this the the
pm was getting very very little support
from his own backbenchers and
i was struck by the the lack of kind of
cheering and the hissing and muttering
and jeering that was going on when he
was delivering his statement
and it just felt very much like you know
complete consensus in parliament that is
rare
and and i suppose madeleine because we
haven't seen the commons as packed as it
was today for so long the isolation of
the prime minister all the more apparent
yes absolutely i mean i think there were
some in tory's circles who felt that um
the having a packed chamber once again
would might be useful to the pm but
actually it was quite the opposite today
you had this the very awkward sort of
visual setting of it so for example you
have next to the prime minister you have
the defense minister ben wallace who
just looked the absolute picture of
misery kind of glaring into the middle
distance occasionally openly huffing and
puffing and you had the the physical
presence of many ex-servicemen mps who
gave incredible speeches
and there was nowhere to hide and i do
think during the in the kind of code
with compliant parliament that we've had
so far um
there's perhaps more opportunity for
ministers to get away with not answering
questions properly um for mps on of all
stripes to kind of indulge in these long
pre-rehearsed statements but now it felt
a bit more like an active parliament in
which um you know that those sort of
sneaky solutions are no longer possible
and kevin the the daily mail pointing
the finger at dominic raab um for being
too busy on holiday to help afghan
translators what what's their
story yeah that he delegated an
important call to the uh the afghan
government to try and get people out
those afghans who worked and cooperated
with britain to bring them here
because he was on holiday didn't make
the call and
dominic robb is
led he's either be very effective or a
charmed life which whichever you you
want to choose of course he stood in for
boris johnson when he was in intensive
care with covert as first secretary of
state he deputises up prime minister's
questions uh but today he looked under a
lot of pressure he was a red-faced uh
shouting at kiers dharma when he pointed
out he'd been on holiday
others wasn't made that point uh you
know he was in a five-star resort on
crete when kabul was falling he came
back on sunday the prime minister was
heading off to the southwest i think he
got as far as somerset and he had to
come back it's it's just not it's just
not good of course every politician is
entitled to a holiday
but if you've just been watching tv
listening to the radio reading
newspapers glancing at the internet
anyone could have seen that the taliban
were advancing at a rapid rate
across uh afghanistan and yet the prime
minister and his deputy both went went
off on holiday and uh
well the prime minister's got problems
but i think so as the the the foreign
secretary his judgment particularly when
we're we're told he was advised not to
go
judgment looks very very flawed on this
uh the guardian also
uh focusing on that wall of fury as it
describes it madeline from all wings of
the conservative party um 11 former
cabinet ministers criticizing the prime
minister and it highlights sorry the
guardian it highlights um
the speech by theresa may former prime
minister and her attack on the
intelligence failures
yes absolutely i mean her speech was was
one of the real standouts of of the
proceedings um i mean that
i suppose that that there was a great
deal of rage in the commons um from all
sides as we've talked about um but i
think you know alongside all of that um
it did feel at times that the level of
there was a kind of
upswell of anger but perhaps a bit less
discussion about
what we're going to do next you know so
the discussion of
rob and his holiday plans there was a
big sort of jeering match between rob
and ian blackford and the speaker had to
intervene and there was a lot of
deserved criticism and finger pointing
but i you know i wonder if alongside
that there could have been a bit more
talk of you know what on earth are we
actually going to do practically to deal
with this disaster that we've
contributed to
um let's have a look at the telegraph
now then kevin and not just the pm and
the foreign secretary under fire at
condemnation of president biden as well
in the commons today
absolutely the telegraph which had boris
johnson as a columnist
which dominic cummings told us uh boris
johnson is a big fan of the telegraph
wants to know what it's saying they they
go on the criticism of the us president
joe biden as does
the times tom tugan dot
soldier mp on the conservative side who
served in afghanistan don dan jarvis
labour mp soldier 2 who served in
afghanistan both in particular uh
went for the for the president not least
on him saying well the afghan if the
afghan army wouldn't fight why wouldn't
why wouldn't the us uh uh why would the
us army fight on their behalf i'm just
pointing out 70 000 uh people in the
afghan army and police have been killed
in this
this conflict
the afghan army is is known not to be
particularly well
paid in fact some weren't paid and paid
at all so it was quite interesting
listening to uh two gundam jobs who are
first and experienced uh speaking
speaking that way and i think it
requires a lot of people to to reassess
but there's no doubt as theresa may
said that and who's turning out to be a
better former prime minister i think
that she was prime minister but then it
was the biden planning
sorry the trump plan implemented by
biden but biden is coming in for a lot
of flack and deservedly so as he tries
to wash his hands of this you can
understand why he wanted the us out of
afghanistan but you have to take some
responsibility for the for the
consequences and the the taliban
so rapidly taking control because that's
just going to create huge problems in
the in the future not least for for
women in
in afghanistan unless they've undergone
some
radical complete change which would uh
would be incredibly surprised
really unlikely
yeah um and let's have a look at the
star front page at madeleine now an
image of a little boy and a plea from
the star for boris johnson to take a
long hard look at the face of this
little boy shame on you and that of joe
barr and that joe biden it says madeline
yes it's a very powerful um very
powerful cover and i think it really
reflects the way in which um however
people in britain might have felt before
the withdrawal however little people had
been following the issue of afghanistan
in general amongst it hadn't featured
heavily in the news all that much um
until recently when when the withdrawal
seemed imminent um it shows just how
quickly that these kind of images are
really sealed into the public
consciousness and that's why they could
prove so very damaging for the people
who've been in charge i i suspect that
some of the
uh images that we've seen that the the
desperate people clinging to planes the
abuse of children and there's likely to
be sadly a lot more of this over the
coming days
babysitting passed over the barbed wire
offense to soldiers as well images that
are going to haunt us for a long time
yeah
i think they'll be haunting in the same
way that you know the image of tank man
on tiananmen square was was has stuck
with people forever you know a picture
paints a thousand words and there are so
many horrible pictures coming out right
now
uh madeline kevin uh thanks very much
indeed don't go away though we're going
to be back in just a couple of minutes
to discuss how schools are planning to
deal with covid once the summer holidays
are over we'll see them
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now kevin mcguire and
madeleine grant but we have some
breaking news to bring you before we
take another look at the pages the
papers and u.s president joe biden has
said that u.s forces will stay in
afghanistan until all americans are
evacuated even if that means staying
beyond august the 31st there have been
concern that u.s forces would pull out
within days at the uk ambassador to
afghanistan saying today that they were
working on the basis of needing to get
people out within days rather than weeks
let's bring in our uh guests this
evening kevin mcguire and madeleine
grant to take a look at the papers we're
going to turn to the telegraph and it
has a story about school plans uh for
covid when schools return interesting
we heard from joe biden in america
earlier
kevin who gave a statement in the white
house about coronavirus not about
afghanistan didn't take any questions
but he did talk about mask wearing in
schools and how imperative it was for
the under-12s who aren't vaccinated to
continue to wear masks not the plan here
what is the uk planning when schools
return
there's still a huge problem across the
united states because of low vaccination
levels in uh in many states but here the
the plan the telegraph say schools have
been advised that if five or more pupils
uh test positive instead of sending
everybody home one of the options is to
have classes outside now of course the
whole pandemic
should be over because it's
now if you're double vaxxed
then you just have to test daily if
you've been in contact with somebody now
most kids aren't going to be actually uh
jabbed by the time schools come back so
the government is looking at other ways
in england of dealing with this uh
lessons outside sounds quite good well
it depends where your school is if
you're next to a busy road or on a very
built-up site so i'm going to be depends
on the weather as well doesn't it
exactly but at least at least right
being trying to be as uh upbeat as
positive uh as i can at least the
government appears to be looking for
solutions now of ways of making uh
making it work and stop disrupting the
education of kids
uh madeleine we are running out of time
but just one other story also on the
front of the telegraph uh geronimo the
alpaca
oh yes um he so he's going to die
according to the high court um and this
um we can expect the alpaca cultural war
to rumble on for some time um i mean i'm
i'm sort of amazed by the attention that
this story has got in the general public
i think it perhaps shows either that
we're a very caring country about the
welfare of animals or that perhaps we've
gone a bit potty over the summer break i
think it's perhaps one of the two
okay
we are out of time